nachdem ich unser büro umgebaut habe und
so die ersten einblicke ins handwerk
gewinnen konnte konnte ich mich immer
mehr dafür begeistern um euch auch dafür
zu begeistern habe ich mich mit macher
gesucht eine aktion des bayerischen
handwerkstags zusammengetan um gemeinsam
für euch content zu produzieren wir
haben fünf handwerker mit verschiedenen
ausbildungsberufen eingeladen max sowie
müssen anhand simpler fragen
herausfinden welcher job zu welcher
person gut der catch es gibt sechs
möglichkeiten aber nur fünf teile machen
viel spaß mit diesem video heimat hallo
day
stellt uns bitte einmal alle
auswahlmöglichkeiten beziehungsweise
berufe vor zwischen den hier aus werden
könnt also wir haben einen schreiner
oder eine schreine raumausstatter oder
daumen auf dafür denn ein maurer oder
eine maurerin weiter mit ihr sohn nick
weiter zugelegt hat einen fotografen
oder eine fotografin und baut suppe die
fu macherin okay ich so auch noch nicht
gehört the sun und das sind die
kandidaten
schau dir gerne genau an du wirst am
ende noch mal die möglichkeit haben alle
berufe durchzuwechseln und deine
entscheidung zu überdenken was denkst du
wie viele jobs du richtig zu teilen ist
ich mache das ja nicht zum ersten mal
hier es ist wie immer ich habe keine
ahnung eigentlich wer heute mal ein
bisschen realistischer schätzen deshalb
frage ich
2 ich würde mal so zwei drei sagen
ungefähre maximum
ich habe mir eine frage überlegt die
nicht jedem stellen ja und zwar es ist
ja handwerk zeigen wir mal deine hände
kann ich mir nämlich schon relativ gut
vorstellen drehmann fotografen wir auch
der fotograf hin da sind vielleicht die
hände weniger beansprucht er schon
können die kuh milan arbeitest du von
deinem beruf zeitlich von 10 bis 19 uhr
oder von 10 bis 18 und von insgesamt
einer stunde 40 stunden noch die
anschlüsse von den dann berufen drin
zweieinhalb jahre sondern das war ja ist
ja das ist noch eine ausbildung genau du
siehst aus als künstler kreativ sein
also auch in deinem beruf zweirad
mechatroniker sich irgendwie nicht
orthopädieschuhmacher weiß wirklich im
beim besten wirklich was ich mir
vorstellen das ist ein exot also ist es
üblich so ein üblicher handwerks job
oder es ist eigentlich nicht so
verbreitet
es wird immer größer was also wenn du
sagst es wird immer größer dann kann ich
mir vielleicht vorstellen
orthopädieschuhmacher weil es kommt ja
auch irgendwie immer mehr ich liebte
immer noch das was sind deine hobbys
surfen ganz viele surfer surfen bringt
nicht viel bringt dich für mich direkt
in den er zum fotografieren weil es ja
auch nicht so genau wer sind deine
eltern in den gleichen beruf tätig du
bist noch so graf ich glaube du bist ein
fotograf macht kurzen prozess
es ist wieder so viel schwerer als
gedacht so man hat kaum anhaltspunkte
irgendwie aber das mit den händen soll
ich echt ne gute idee aber ich finde man
sollte nicht wie geht es dir sehr gut
das heißt du bist schon mal keine
schwangerschaft bis zum 22 22 bisschen
ausbildung fertig wirst du dann gesellen
oder hast du dann noch mal weiter
gemacht ich bin christ allem im ersten
lehrjahr also so fertig ausgebildet also
hast du bevor du den beruf aufgenommen
hat schon kontakt mit dem berufsfeld
gehabt ja okay kommt das daher dass du
in einem familienbetrieb tätig bist
exakt okay aber das zu innen und außen
sowohl auch die eigentlich in jedem
besucher nicht nur üblich habe arbeitet
man innen und außen auch als produkte
darauf eigentlich da ich deine hände mal
sehen
ja es könnte sein dass hände sind mit
denen gearbeitet wird mein erstes gefühl
das traumhaus dabei glaube ich weil das
machen eher frauen denke ich mal wieder
dichter regen die was schief geht oder
so nicht dann auch nicht fotograf
malerin und schreinerin ich habe glaube
ich mal gehört dass im maurerhandwerk
die frauenquote super gering ist also es
wäre wahrscheinlich echt
unwahrscheinlich dass die maurerin bist
deshalb würde ich vielleicht einfach auf
schreinerin gehen okay du bist mein
schrank
marco freut mich arbeitest du indoor
oder outdoor in der komplett komplex zu
100% zu 100 prozent ist nicht mein
maurer
fertig ist die eigenständig werke an
oder machst du das team im team mal so
mal so erstes bauchgefühl der eventuelle
zweite zone
arbeitest du kreativ ja würde man 2 hat
mechatronik als kreativ bezeichnet wenn
man bei jappy also arbeitet das ist ein
traditionsbetrieb ja schon nach sonja
dann nehme ich selbst fotograf raus und
dann bin ich erst bei maurer oder
schreiner also maurer bist du schon mal
nicht musst du nichts zu sagen wir haben
deine eltern reagiert als du gesagt hast
dass du deinen aufnimmst google
überzeugt davon also schon mal kein only
cent
arbeitest du auch hauptsächlich draußen
na na na okay dann war da wird auch in
der alle viel gearbeitet und
bin jetzt gerade zwischen
raumausstatter und orthopädieschuhmacher
in die orthopädisch werden ich weiß
ich hoffe dass ich habe die hand frage
nicht gestellt da habe ich sie noch
stellen nein scheiße du hast jetzt circa
die hälfte der leute durch bist du
zufrieden mit deiner bisherigen auswahl
und was glaubst du wie viele der leute
die bis dato wichtig hast also ich
glaube dass ich den verein save richtig
ab also vom bauchgefühl her und ich
denke da muss da bin ich auch ganz gut
so was mein gefühl sagt mit dem einen
oder der anderen schon ein gutes gefühl
aber 100 prozent bei keinem
was so los ist
sagt ist immer da ist der deinem beruf
bei der familie tradition ja auch ein
familienbetrieb das hat man echt häufig
mit familienbetriebe die sind am start
auf jeden fall in die kita generation
seid ihr ich bin jetzt
stark und es ist ein beruf sehr weit
verbreitet ist also machen den viele
oder ganz okay also eigentlich so ein
waltroper dürften die farbe ist jetzt
zum maurer ich weiß nicht wie das
vorstellen können sie magst du es gerne
ich wäre zu heben oder es ist ein
problem für dich und mag
aber es gibt ja jetzt hat auch
versetzung hilfe und sowas
und man das ist ein gutes stichwort
ersetzen sondern dass dies etwas kennt
arbeit zu ehrende oder ausbauen sowohl
als auch
okay das heißt sie jetzt zweirad
mechatronik macht man natürlich weniger
outdoor würde ich jetzt behaupten
orthopädieschuhmacher in wird
wahrscheinlich auch finanziell eher
indoor arbeiten das heißt ich habe noch
maurerin aber das war ein englisches
videos gesehen welches das 99 prozent
aller maurer also aller menschen dieser
beruf ausüben männlich sind damit habe
ich jetzt dann vielleicht ein problem
ich muss jetzt mal welche das jetzt
einfach mal die mörderin sicher ich
gucke dann mal hattest du bevor du den
beruf auch was schon interesse an dem
beruf ja aber ich habe mir das anders
gemacht also ich habe am anfang wie ich
überlegt habe den beruf zu machen
ziemlich gesellschaftlichen und
familiären druck bekommen das ist nicht
machen also obwohl deine familie den job
in vierter generation ausübt wollten sie
dass du ihn vielleicht nicht mal
irgendwie passt das nicht zu
orthopädieschuhmacher das tierheim
dürftig fragen ob sie sich für
motorsport interessiert ja bist du das
nicht besonders weil sich jeder 23
tonica interessiert für motorsport hat
das ja nicht an bedenken mit hochachtung
vor erfahrung
gut dass richter auskennen ist ja
interessant
vielleicht sogar für gute frage aber
warum ich verstehe gar nicht mehr warum
sollte sie das nicht machen ist voll
cool hallo ich bin es der letzte jetzt
habe ich noch zwei
auswahlmöglichkeiten der fotograf und
zwei hat mich jetzt erstmal coole schuhe
findest du die schule orthopädisch
wertvoll dazu habe ich keine meinung
weil er keine fachlichen
und das ist ein weit verbreiteter
handwerksberuf oder also so viele machen
ihn gar nicht tatsächlich weniger als
man denkt sagt mir deine hände
scheiße die frage ist doch nicht so gut
wird hätte ich das dann ein bisschen was
viel steht neben nicht so wirklich oh
mann ich glaube ich und wie sind so
deine arbeitszeiten ganz normal 9 bis 18
uhr 9 bis 18 uhr auf dem ich um 9 uhr an
das heißt du bist mein orthopäde gilt
dank gibt es irgendwie eine spezielle
anleitung das immer das genau so machen
muss
also gibt jetzt den
fotografen
damit halte ich mein maurer übrig ich
habe auf jeden fall alle jobs verteilt
ich hoffe richtig aber für jetzt gerade
habe ich eigentlich ganz gutes gefühl so
wie das ist eine auswahl das jetzt noch
einmal die chance die jobs zu wechseln
und möglicherweise anzupassen wenn du
irgendwo nicht ganz zufrieden bist was
ist ultra vielleicht ist wirklich maurer
nicht dabei bei maurer finde ich ist so
ein ganz klassisches dinge wurden in
meinen kopf ein steak aber es wird nicht
funktionieren ich glaube ich habe
einfach doch rasiert haben doch alle
richtig
okay das ist dein ergebnis
ich wusste das ist von einer
fahrradkette ich dachte nur irgendwie so
sagst du auch sowieso skaten deshalb
dachte halt fotos weil das so nah dabei
ist meint sie auch surfen kreativ siehst
du alle mal aus danke dann bist du quasi
zweirad mechatroniker genau
gut ich habe nicht mal was vorstellen
ich liebe also nochmals relativ
eindeutig du bist der fotograf ja
das ist richtig was ist das für ein
werkzeug an seinen stamm einzelnen noch
nie gesehen aber sehr professionell
gemacht was bestellung super doch meinen
ja
die statistik zeigt das ist ultra selten
ich bin halt dass ein prozent coal
machst du den job ich mag es wirklich
recht gefeiert und raumausstatter ich
dachte kurz als ich die arbeitslose
gesehen habe aber in meinem kopf war
raumausstatter vielleicht soviel 3d
planung will kriegt man die hose trägt
man kleber zum beispiel mit
spachtelmasse wenn man am boden lag zum
beispiel cool aber ich habe es gesagt ja
gesagt zwei von 15 richtig
zwischenzeitlich weiß vielleicht bei
alle sind richtig aber ja 25 sowie und
dein ergebnis ist dass
du siehst jetzt die leute mit deinen
zuordnung in ihrer richtigen
arbeitskleidung ich war der orthopäde
und eigentlich war am herd roniger also
du hast mich richtig zugeteilt der
fotograf ich war die raumausstatterin
bin aber eigentlich reine
richtig aber ich find's cool so
allgemein das auch so in männerberufen
viele frauen mittlerweile eingehen
ausfall sei es zum beispiel bei mir in
der berufsschule ich bin die einzige
aber das gefühl dass du lebst
lässt sich gut lieber rasch rainer aber
richtig fahrt rastatter
zwar richtig von 5 war ja eigentlich so
auf mein ziel
tobias auf 255 richtig super also es
gibt keine verlierer in diesem
wunderbaren format das ist jedes mal
wieder eine achterbahnfahrt weil man
kann sich nicht sicher sein ob man es
richtig macht und was mich angeht wenn
ich mich jetzt umschauen jeder kann
wirklich alles machen also das macht das
format so schwer und so interessant dass
man rein von der optik wird sich einfach
viel sagen kann dann würde ich sagen
vielen dank fürs zuschauen im namen von
dave cobb ersten video auch wieder rein
und lassen aber da weil dafür super